-Doctors are asking people
on TikTok
to stop sticking garlic cloves
up their nose
to clear their sinuses.
I feel like this happens
once a month
where people do something
dangerous they see online.
So I wrote a tiny song about it.
Hope you enjoy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
♪ I have to tell you something
that everybody knows ♪
♪ You shouldn't stick a clove
of garlic up into your nose ♪
♪ Don't do it ♪
♪ No, don't do it ♪
♪♪
♪ The doctors
are concerned for you ♪
♪ It really isn't great ♪
♪ Did you bump your head ♪
♪ When you fell
off a milk crate? ♪
♪ Don't do it ♪
♪ No, no, don't do it ♪
♪♪
♪ Garlic is for pasta
or a nice vinaigrette ♪
♪ But if you stick it
up your sniffer ♪
♪ All you get is some regret ♪
♪ Don't do it ♪
♪ No, no, no, don't do it ♪
One more time.
♪ Sticking stuff into your nose
really isn't good ♪
♪ But if you're talking
'bout a COVID test ♪
♪ I really think you should ♪
♪ So do it ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, you should do it ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Whistling ]